[Musique]
c'est un cerf
et
[Musique]
et c'est à dire est que julia gillard ce
que ce n'est pas pour ça vous regarde et
on joue on fera des marins environnants
vous allez prononcer ce mot vous allez
donc faire un tour nietzsche a bâti en
australie avec deux lots les amis bon
ben je me prépare pour vous retrouver à
la librairie valentin dans le xvème à
paris pour une séance de dédicaces un
petit peu particulière ce que c'est une
séance de dédicace du livre tout à fait
normal sauf que tout va au téléthon donc
vraiment je compte sur vous on h arrivée
des pmp je ferai c'est dans les loges à
l'armée dans les loges puis je fais
croire à tout le monde que je vais
bosser démission après il fait beau
c'est que dalle je prive loges d'une
meuf
bah en fait j'ai une tête à la porte le
nom de voir cette pièce là ya pas de
fenêtre actifs là en fait je vais
préparer l'émission mais je vais dormir
ouais ouais parce que là je vais dormir
et je vous embrasse fait qu'ils arrivent
là maintenant et dames et messieurs les
issues c'est bien c'est elle a rien
derrière di caprio derrière non mais je
rêve
il a mangé un gâteau il venu il sait
mais tout en haut du plan de travail
pour bouffer du ghetto quoi du gâteau
aux pommes
avec s'enregistrer les mises sur le
matelas on avait mis tous nos bureaux on
bosse en bosse on bosse et puis pouf sac
à dos
je vous dis que guillaume aujourd'hui
est exceptionnel comme la semaine
dernière des très bons mots qui te
ressemble d'assez drôle si effectivement
c'est l'agrès n'y avait pas beaucoup de
monde un public
mais voilà je vais les gros bisous
[Musique]